cersei is the rogue agent
credited with converting fey lau over to
the black tusk
so with this in mind what more can she
add to the story behind the former
second wave commander
going rogue
[Music]
[Music]
alicia coswald callsign cersei
grew up in brooklyn new york although
she didn't come from money
she more than made up for it with
determination and dedication
cersei is a confident proud american
citizen with an optimistic and positive
attitude towards everything she sets her
mind to
after doing a tour in the army she took
advantage of the gi bill
a law that was introduced in 1944 that
helps veterans with the funding towards
education
including college graduate school and
other training programs
it was during this time that she was
approached and then recruited by the
division
after graduating college cersei went on
to teach english as a high school
teacher
and it was around this time that the
dollar flew was first released
into new york city it wasn't long after
she was activated
that she realized that the division was
hopelessly unprepared for the situation
they were facing
as a strong patriotic individual she
believed that the shd
didn't have what it took to get the
country through these difficult times
cersei was eventually approached by the
black tusk having already lost faith in
the division
it didn't take much convincing to bring
her over to this side
some time after the black tusk made
themselves known to the division
and invaded washington dc cersei was
captured by agent feylau
i know you're working with someone
careful
you don't want to make isaac upset
he hit me like that again he'll think
you've gone rogue you teamed up with the
jtf
we do what we have to you got a
concussion you're the one who isn't
thinking straight
what's your mission agent to save what
remains
to ensure survival that we live on that
when we finally get back on our feet
there is something left to stand on
cool story faye and how's that working
out for you it's hard
but we're stable sure for now
what about next week or the week after
or when you haven't had a sarah delivery
for months and the medicine runs out and
the people who work together
so well right now turn on one another
what are you gonna do then faye
we will adapt we will work together and
find a way to move forward
and when they steal your tech and turn
your turrets against you
what'll you do then faye what i have to
alicia
i'm doing the same you're not there yet
but you'll see we're the same
i'm not like you i'm not a traitor i'm
not a traitor
i'm effective i can see where this is
going and who can
actually make a change you'll figure it
out eventually
or you'll die either way my boys will
find me soon enough and then you'll need
to make a choice
what choice is that to let me go
or see if you're good enough to take on
my team
who are you working with still haven't
figured it out
thought you were better than this i just
want to confirm it
you scared never you should be we took
out the lmb
i'm not afraid of black tusk so you are
as smart as you pretend to be i'm a lot
of things
you shouldn't underestimate me now tell
me about your first meeting with
schaefer
how do you know about schaefer
susie was surprised to learn that faye
knew of baden schaefer
had she too been approached by him were
they still in contact
regardless faye eventually agreed to
release her
cersei would regroup with the black tusk
although she was the one being
interrogated
cersei had learned a lot from their
interactions
a certain vulnerability a degree of
doubt and phase eyes
cersei talked to schaefer about the
potential of a new valuable asset
towards the black tusk cause
she get anything out of you nothing we
didn't want her to she gonna be a
problem
pretty sure she's an asset you think
she's ready she's desperate
a little push and she's one of us is
that a good idea
no one has better access to the division
than faye
we bring her to our side we'll know
where all the bodies are buried
then it's just a matter of time before
they fall and we rise
although apprehensive about the idea
schaefer takes cersei's feedback on
board
and proceeds with plans to entice fey
over to this side
some times passed the division has
managed to locate and eliminate kinase
rogue agents
and eventually the man himself and this
is when it was made known that feylau
herself
has gone rogue i can't believe we're
working together again
ah sorry about the black site
i get it you didn't know what this was
you're right i had no idea what this was
i'm starting to understand though i'm
glad you signed on
i always liked you faye i like you too
alicia use my call sign
cersei makes it less weird alicia's too
personal
reminds me of life before this [ __ ] fair
enough
you want a call sign for this op no
it's better if i remember where i came
from
cersei confides in fey welcoming her to
the team with open arms
forgiving her for a lack of
understanding from the earlier
interactions
but it wasn't long before schaefer gave
faye her own team to work with
and one of the first assignments she
gave out to cersei was to get the
location
and schedule of president ellis
what do you need just a location and
schedule should be a piece of cake for
you cersei
whose location and schedule do you need
chicken hawk
that's need to know faye you know that
i need to know what do you want it for
just need to make sure that he's not in
any danger
getting rumblings about transports and
mobile units outside of dc
going through maryland just want to
confirm that chicken hawks not in any
danger
although suspicious of her reasoning
cersei gets her the information
schaefer really knows how to pick them
hey he picked me we're different
his original squad complete fuck-ups
you're not wrong
how do you lose the pentagon how do you
lose a bioreactor
you know i i still can't tell if it's
incompetence or a leak a leak
someone on the inside leaking intel to
the division why would you say something
like that makes more sense than wyvern
losing the antivirals and random agents
getting lucky
wyvern wasn't stable on the best of days
for an elite squad
our comms should be secure we shouldn't
be having these leaks
isaac's good but he's not that good
there's no way that we should be
compromised like this maybe someone
programmed a back door into our coms
relay just pumping intercepted radio to
some data analyst in a basement under
the lincoln memorial
makes sense viper i was kidding
jesus you need to get laid you're wound
too tight
you might be right but i wouldn't let
any of these
chucklefox touch me they're not exactly
my type
acknowledging the failings of schaefer's
original squad cersei proclaims that
this time is different
and when the time came she set forth
executing her part in the operation
taking a unit of btsu she started
capturing locations of interest in
southern manhattan
multiple sites were captured in battery
park the financial district
civic centre and two bridges
but much like the many rogue agents the
division have come across in the past
they were able to stop the rogue
advances
the shd were able to quickly and
efficiently remove any trace of her
movements
in new york and eventually caught up to
her
cersei put up a tough fight in fact it
took the agents a couple more attempts
than i they would ever like to admit to
however in the end she was no match for
them
and was ultimately killed in the fight
i had hoped to include the conclusion of
fey lau in this video
but due to me being already a little
late to the party with this and also
the fact that i'd like to put a little
more of my time into the thoughts around
what had happened
because i really don't feel that what we
saw in game did her story justice
before i finish this up i'd really like
to thank the people who have gone out of
their way to become members of the
channel especially some of the more
recent high tier editions
i haven't asked for permission so i
won't be displaying any names apart from
jeremy pontier you beautiful bastard
given all that is happening in the world
during this time and the fact that so
many families are struggling to get
through it including
the economic impact to places as
isolated as new zealand i can't thank
you enough
you are literally helping feed my
children it's no secret that this
channel is purely a hobby for me
when times get tough hobbies are the
first to go but because of this sort of
support i'm stoked to be able to
continue doing this
however for everyone else please don't
feel like this is me reaching up for
more in all honesty your viewership and
in some cases
intense support is more than enough this
is just helping to tie it in with other
priorities
while there is interest in what i'm
producing i'll do my best to continue
doing it
otherwise thank you very much for
watching and i'll catch in the next one
cheers
[Applause]
[Music]
uh